WAI CHEE DIMOCK: I just
want to refresh your
memory about what we talked
about last time, about the
kindness of strangers.
Last time we spent a lot of
time talking about the
kindness of strangers, and in
many ways, this as an instance
of Faulkner updating a long
tradition of thinking about
hospitality, and also thinking
about pregnancy outside of
wedlock, or even when you are in
a marriage that the father
is not your husband --
so Lena updating Leda from
the Greek classics.
But also thinking about
community, and thinking about
Lena's relation to the Southern
community, and
updating Southern hospitality as
an updating of the ancient
Greek idea of hospitality
to strangers.
So today we'll be thinking
more about that, but
introducing a new term,
and bringing
Christianity into play.
You guys probably know this--
Christianity is very important
in Light in August, and
especially the Christian concept
of how we should
conduct ourselves towards
our neighbors.
So we'll be thinking about
that, and the various
permutations that Christian
idea, treat
your neighbor as thyself.
But before we go into that, I
just want to talk a little bit
about the narrative structure of
Light in August. Obviously
Lena is one very important
half of the narrative.
She represents the undramatic
half of the narrative, very
peaceful, very monotonous.
The only way drama can come into
her part of the story is
when the supporting cast takes
over and they kind of upstage
her and become the protagonist
within just that
short period of time.
So the undramatic narrative
revolving around Lena and
those people that she comes
into contact with.
And then opposite to
that is a very
dramatic structure, actually.
And we're beginning to see
that in the reference to
Joanna Burden and her house
being burned down, and the
spectators saying that it would
be good to have some
"human fat meat" to
quicken the fire.
So very, very dramatic
development, and various other
characters also contribute to
that dramatic narrative.
So we'll be looking at Joanna
Burden, Reverend Hightower,
and obviously Joe Christmas.
But I just want to start by
going back and looking
squarely at this injunction
from Leviticus, which is
probably one of the central
tenets of Christianity.
And we should take it, not just
the last line, which is
the line that all of
us know, but take
it in its full context.
"You shall not take vengeance
or bear a grudge against the
sons of your own people, but you
shall love your neighbor
as yourself.
I am the Lord." So loving your
neighbor is in the context of
you obeying God.
So it is under the rubric of
your devotion to God, your
obedience to God that you should
love your neighbor.
But it's further thickened by
the notion that you should not
take vengeance against others.
We might not necessarily
think of the
prohibition against vengeance.
In fact, we don't really
associate Christianity with
the prohibition again
vengeance.
There's just no prohibition
against vengeance in our
current legal and ethical
thinking.
Punitive justice is an instance
of, actually,
collective vengeance.
And so it is institutionalized.
There's no prohibition
against vengeance.
But actually within, at least,
Leviticus, there's a
prohibition against vengeance.
So if you think about what that
means, and putting that
also under the rubric of
loving your neighbor--
so all this is very important to
Light in August. But I want
to further introduce one other
consideration, which is a
relatively new book that came
out by three very important
thinkers and philosopher, Slavoj
Zizek, Eric Santner,
and Kenneth Reinhardt
called The Neighbor.
The three of them each
had an essay in this
book called The Neighbor.
And the argument is really
thinking about what the
concept of neighbor could mean
after the Holocaust, and after
the numerous instances of
genocide that we've witnessed
in the twentieth century and
the twenty-first century.
It seems that the human
propensity is to turn against
those among whom you've
lived all your life.
It takes such a short
space of time.
Generations of people
might be living
together in the same place--
all of a sudden, you turn
against the person
next door to you.
So the three philosophers think
of this as a case of
political theology.
This is a very interesting
concept.
It's thinking about the ethics
of social conduct, of
behavior, towards people who are
not kin to you, who have
no blood ties to you, you have
no obligation other than just
the obligation of treating them
as neighbors, and what
the appropriate conduct would
be, what are the limits to
being someone's neighbors,
and what are the licenses
that you can take.
So I'd encourage you just to
take a look at this book, if
you just want to do some
reading in philosophy.
But now let's go back to what
we've been talking about a
little bit last time, and I
just want to remind you of
this discussion, this
conversation becomes right at
the heels of thinking about
Byron Bunch being in love.
"'It's a big fire,'
another said.
'What can it be?
I don't remember anything out
that way big enough to make
all that smoke, except that
Burden house.' 'Maybe that's
what it is,' another said.
'My pappy says he can remember
how 50 years ago, folks said
it ought to be burned, with a
little human fat meat to start
it good.' 'Maybe your pappy
slipped up there and set it
afire,' a third said.
They all laughed."
So this is the other face
of the community.
Going along with Lena, we have
this idea that human beings
are just all kindness, and
that's all there is.
But we just know from experience
that that's
probably just half the story.
So Faulkner is very emphatic
about showing us the other
face of the neighbor.
And there's a genealogy
to the Burden house.
In Kipling's poem, "The White
Man's Burden," that people who
do good, or consider themselves
to do good, quite
often actually incur the
resentments of those
they do good to.
It's an interesting kind of
psychological dynamics.
"Take up the White Man's
burden--/ And reap his old
reward:/ The blame of those ye
better,/ The hate of those ye
guard."
I think that it actually is
quite a natural human tendency
not to want to get other people
taking care of you in
this particular way, of
doing good to you.
And so resentment is actually
kind of natural reaction.
And what the White Man's Burden
means, especially in
the context of doing good
to a different race.
And obviously that issue, it
was front and center during
reconstruction, when you have
all the slaves becoming
freemen, and what to do--
and how to educate them and
induct them, really, into
citizenship.
So lots of Northern reformers
went South, and a lot of them,
including Joanna Burden's
family, had the idea that they
would be there as social
reformers, and would be
educating the ex-slaves.
But they also went by a
different name in American
history, and that is the name
of the carpetbagger.
And we can see a very vivid
illustration of that, the huge
bag that is more than an
appendage, really.
It's the defining feature
of this person.
And there were many, many
cartoons about how much they
were resented in post-bellum
South.
So there's this is one image
of how doing good, or the
claim to do good, can actually
benefit yourself.
Likewise, the self groaning
under the burden of the-- how
did that go?
It's an actual burden
right there.
And I'm not entirely clear
about the logic of this.
You guys should just try to
figure it out, and email, or
just write a blog about this, or
email me, if you can figure
out the exact logic.
Anyway, there's resentment
there, but it's complicated.
So political cartoons can be
really a great way to think
about political history and
social history, and certainly
a very important background
to Light in August.
But what we now see is
the outcome of that.
Joanna Burden, as we know, is
still there as someone who's
doing good.
She is on the board of multiple
charities, she gives
money, she has a black lawyer.
Basically she's spent her whole
life working towards the
welfare of the black
population.
And this is what happens to her
at the end of that life.
But the way that Faulkner is
telling the story, the actual
tone of that is very
different from the
tone that I just used.
"'She was lying on the floor.
Her head had been cut pretty
near off.'" Oh, this is--
as is the custom in
Light in August--
a very dramatic episode is
rendered to us, is retold to
us by someone who was there,
but not a central
player in the story.
So this whole discovery of
Joanna Burden's body was
reported by Byron Bunch
to Hightower.
And Byron wasn't there to do
the discovering, either.
He was reporting what a
countryman who was a total
stranger, and coming to town in
a wagon, a total stranger,
being given this important
function of discovering Joanna
Burden's body.
So this is this countryman
from nowhere,
telling about the event.
"'She was lying on the floor.
Her head had been cut pretty
near off; a lady with the
beginning of gray hair.
The man said how he stood there
and he could hear the
fire and there was smoke in the
room itself now, like it
had done followed him in.
And how he was afraid to try to
pick her up and carry her
out, because her head might
come clean off.
So he run back into the house
and up the stairs again and
into the room and jerked the
cover off the bed and rolled
her onto it like
a sack of meal.
And he said that what he
was scared of happened.
Because the cover fell open and
she was laying on her side
facing one way, and her head was
turned clean around like
she was looking behind her.
And he said that if she could've
just done that when
she was alive, she might
not have been
doing it now.'" OK.
Faulkner is actually repeating
himself, right?
It's the same kinds of
construction that Lena used
when she talks about herself
climbing out of the window for
the last time.
It was a little difficult, that
time, but if it had been
that difficult from the first
time, she might not need to be
doing it now, right?
So it's exactly the
same structure.
What is weird is that even in
Lena's case-- even though it
could have been seen as a
totally unfunny story, it's
told in a funny way.
And this episode is--
it's really hard to see how it
could be funny in any fashion,
except for the way Faulkner has
chosen to tell the story.
So this is something very deep
in Faulkner, that his
temptation, his compulsion, is
to tell a tragic story from a
comic point of view.
And we can the speculate
about why this is such
a pattern in him.
But I think that he really
doesn't want to give tragedy
the entirety of the field.
If we can think of the narrative
field as either
full-occupancy or
half-occupancy, tragedy is
granted no more than half
occupancy of the narrative
field at any given moment.
And maybe it's not even
half; here it seems to
be less than half.
So here's the country man
worrying about all the things
that one really shouldn't be
worrying about when you're
discovering a dead body.
And the very contrived plot
detail that Joanna Burden's
head is turned around, so
she's looking backwards.
And it turns out that there's
actually a very venerable
genealogy to that particular
configuration of the dead
human body or human head
in relation to
the rest of the body.
It turns out that the epic is
coming into play as well,
because in the Divine Comedy,
in Canto XX, there's a very
famous episode of Dante and
Virgil going to hell and
seeing all these people in
hell being punished, and
Dante's way of punishment is by
the logic of contrapasso,
that the punishment is the
repetition of your crime.
So this is what he sees--
a whole group of people
with heads set around.
"As I inclined my head still
more, I saw that each,
amazingly, appeared contorted
between the chin and where the
chest begins.
They had their faces twisted
toward the haunches, and found
it necessary to walk backwards
because they could not see
ahead of them." And this is
an illustration, a Flaxman
illustration, of all these
people in hell, their heads
turned backwards.
And the reason that they are
punished in this particular
way is that in life, they
were soothsayers.
They claimed to be foreseeing
the future.
And of course, in Dante's
cosmos, this quite sever
Christian cosmos, unlike the
Greek tradition, human beings
are not really supposed to know
anything about the future.
Foreknowledge is not
a privilege that
human beings can claim.
So as a consequence of claiming
foreknowledge of the
future, these people were
punished in hell by having
their heads turned backwards.
And we can also think of
Faulkner, in many ways,
thinking of this as a fit
punishment for social reformers.
Social reformers also claim to
have some kind of privileged
relation to the future, and
they're reforming the present
quite often because they have
this vision about the future.
They want the present to
approximate the vision of the
future that they can see.
So maybe that is the connection
between Joanna and
these ancient soothsayers.
So there's a kind of a thematic
connection, but the
tonal connection is different.
If we think about Dante's
incidents in the Divine
Comedy, there's just
no humor in it.
It's a terrible sight to see
all the people with their
heads turned backwards.
And likewise, in this
representation, there's
nothing funny about this.
It could have been done in a
funny fashion, but it's never
done in a funny fashion,
whereas Faulkner's
representation of Joanna
is definitely comic.
So it seems that every time, any
time Faulkner invokes an
analogy from a prior text,
it's always rewriting the
text, and changing especially
the tone of that episode.
So from Joanna, we get a kind of
complicated picture of the
malice of neighbors.
Well, actually, she's not killed
by her neighbors, as
we'll find out.
So even though the neighbors
are kind of rejoicing and
having a lot of fun over the
fact that she is killed, and
that her house is
burning down--
even though they are enjoying
it, they're actually not the
instruments for her killing.
So that's important
to remember.
And also that Faulkner, for
some reason, chooses to
approach it from a very odd
angle, so that it's not
exactly sympathy that Faulkner
is trying to
generate from the reader.
We should ask, what kind of
readers' responses he's is
cultivating in that particular
episode, but it's definitely
not sympathy for Joanna.
So that puts us in a very
peculiar relation as well,
because in some sense, we are
the neighbors to Joanna.
We are just like those neighbors
who have some fun at
her expense.
We the readers are also having
some fun at her experience.
So that is the kind
of narrative that
Faulkner is giving us.
But to move on to the next
figure, who also enacts a kind
of dance, a permutation of the
various meanings of neighbor--
and this one, actually, is given
more space in terms of
this full development of the
various incarnations of the
concept of neighbor.
So this is the Reverend
Hightower, who came to town,
and then all of a sudden he
loses his job as a minister,
and then rumors start going
around about his relation with
blacks, as well.
And this is what happens
to him one night.
"Because that evening, some men,
not masked either, took
the negro man out"--
this is the cook-- "took the
negro man out and whipped him.
And when Hightower waked the
next morning his study window
was broken and on the floor lay
a brick with a note tied
to it, commanding him to get
out of town by sunset and
signed K.K.K. And he did not go,
and on the second morning
a man found him in the woods
about a mile from town.
He had been tied to a tree
and beaten unconscious."
So this is exactly
the same people--
the same people who
were kind to Lena
probably were all Klansmen.
It was quite a common --
it has very deep roots,
actually, in some Southern
communities.
And lots of people were Klansmen
that you might not
think would be Klansmen.
New studies also have shown that
actually lots of women
were Klansmen, as well.
So we just don't know who--
whether, in this case,
it was just men.
But what is interesting--
there are actually two
interesting facts about this.
One is that the men
are not masked.
I think that that says a lot.
That actually, in any kind of
Klan action, the people would
be hooded, so you don't actually
see the faces.
But this is a variation
on that.
These men are not hooded,
they're not masked.
So that's a very important
thing, revealing their
identities fully to Hightower.
And then the other detail is
that obviously they want
Hightower to leave town,
and he does not go.
Even though he's beaten
unconscious, he still refuses
to leave. So these two are very
important variations to
the customary story about
Klan violence.
And we'll see what
comes from that.
That Faulkner's both giving us
a very recognizable Southern
history, but also, he's giving
us a very important variation
on this Southern history.
So let's follow the kind
of permutation of
the malice of strangers.
"He refused to tell
who had done it.
The town knew that that was
wrong, and some of them men
came to him and tried again
to persuade him to leave
Jefferson, for his own good,
telling him that next time
they might kill him.
But he refused to leave. He
would not talk about the
beating, even when they offered
to prosecute the men
who had done it.
But he would do neither.
He would neither tell
nor depart.
And then all of a sudden, the
whole thing seemed to blow
away like an evil wind.
It was as though the town
realized at last that he would
be a part of its life until he
died, and that they might as
well become reconciled."
So this is the crucial,
different story that Faulkner
is telling about Southern
history.
Is that the malice of
your neighbors is
the starting point.
It is not the endpoint.
It would be too easy, too much
of a cliche to say these
people are just bigoted.
And they're going to persecute
anyone who's
not of the same mind.
It would be much too
simple to say that.
So this is the very important
variation.
The men are not masked.
They put it within Hightower's
power to report them.
And the town is, in fact, ready
to prosecute those men.
So in fact the legal action is
about to get started, and
certainly there's actionable
violence.
But just as those people who
were beating Hightower put it
within his power to report on
him, he refuses to use that
power that they've put
into his hands.
So this is a strange
kind of symmetry.
For me, this is the most
interesting and compelling
kind of reciprocity--
that you put yourself in the
power of someone that you
hate, and you don't use the
power that those whom you
hate, or those who hate you,
have vested in your hands.
Given the fact that there's so
much violence going on, this
is actually an incredibly
delicate ethical gesture on
both their parts.
And I would say that this is--
I don't know how, I mean, maybe
this is too utopian.
I'm just reporting to you, this
is what I think Faulkner
is doing, that this is the way
that he would like to tell the
story, and it's just the way
that he hopes that human
beings will conduct themselves
under those circumstances.
I should also point out that
actually, in the book that I
mentioned earlier, The Neighbor,
there's actually a
strong argument in favor of
ethical violence, that
sometimes you just can't help
doing violence to someone, but
how to be ethical about that.
So for me, this actually is
an instance of ethical--
qualified, highly
qualified, but
nonetheless, ethical violence.
And I think it's because
of that.
Because actually, this is
violence within limits.
It is violence that actually has
a degree of lawfulness to
it, in the sense that the law
is going to prosecute them.
And those perpetrators actually
have put themselves
under the jurisdiction
off the law.
There's a degree of lawfulness
to that kind of violence
because of that.
Though I think that Hightower
actually has this to say about
his neighbors.
Hightower says, "'They
are good people.
They must believe what they must
believe, especially as it
was I who was at one time
both master and
servant of their believing.
And so it is not for me to
outrage their believing nor
for Byron Bunch to say
that they were wrong.
Because all that any man can
hope for is to be permitted to
live quietly among
his fellows."
So this is one kind of idea.
It's that you can't really
change what people
believe about you.
They can have all kinds of
wrong beliefs about you--
there's no way you can
change those beliefs.
There's no way you can
change how some other
people feel about you.
Feeling is not something that
you can dictate, and other
people, if they happen to hate
you, there's nothing you can
do about that.
So that is a very tough-minded
evaluation of the privacy of
certain kinds of sentiment that
are not pretty, that do
not make for harmonious
relations among human beings.
And hatred is a very powerful
reality for Faulkner.
So you just have to live with
that, that some people just
don't like you all much.
And given the fact that, how can
you still manage to live
quietly and peacefully among
people who don't like
you all that much?
That is the ethical challenge
for Hightower.
So all this suggests that for
him, for now, at this moment--
on page 75--
Hightower is the voice of a
certain kind of ethical norm
in Faulkner.
And it's not surprising that
his name is Hightower.
It's almost kind of very
elevated, very high kind,
maybe impossibly high kind,
of ethical norm.
Very few of us actually
can behave as he
does at this moment.
But I think that we should also
be aware that Hightower
actually doesn't occupy that
moral height all time.
Just as the narrative field
is quite often a field of
half-occupancy --
nothing can fully occupy
that field --
moral elevation is also a place
where you can't have
full command all the time.
So this is a sullen, distant
image of Hightower from the
town's point of view.
People don't like him
all that much.
What they think about
Hightower.
"But the town said to Hightower
that if Hightower"--
and this is not talking about
his black cook anymore, and
not talking about
the violence.
They're talking about something
else, to other
things about Hightower.
One is that he seems complete
fixated on the Civil War.
He seems completely fixated on
this grandfather's death in
the Civil War.
The horse is galloping.
That is the reality for him.
And the other, his wife is going
crazy in that marriage,
and he doesn't seem to be able
to do anything about it.
So this is the town's commentary
on those two other
aspects of Hightower's life, and
you can see why he doesn't
have full command of the ethical
elevation that we've
just seen him in.
"But the town said that if
Hightower had just been a more
dependable kind of man, the kind
of man a minister should
be, instead of being born about
30 years after the only
day he seemed to have
ever lived in--
the day when his grandfather
was shot from
the galloping horse--
she would have been all
right too." The wife.
"But he was not, and the
neighbors would hear her
weeping in the parsonage in
the afternoons or late at
night, and the neighbors knowing
that the husband would
not know what to do about it
because he did not know what
was wrong."
So all of a sudden the
neighbors have been
transformed from the
perpetrators of violence to an
independent voice
of judgment on
Hightower and on the marriage.
They're functioning more like
a Greek chorus in the sense
that they have some knowledge
about the marriage that is
denied to Hightower himself.
And so we should not forget for
a minute that a man who
has such a delicate ethical
understanding of a certain
kind of situation having to do
with violence that is done to
himself can be completely blind
in another situation
where it would have been good
for him to be just a little
more sensitive.
So there's the utter lack of
sensitivity in Hightower that
qualifies his claim
to that ethical
height that we've seen.
It's a totally different
issue.
It doesn't take away from the
beating, it doesn't take away
from the Klan action, but it
does suggest that Hightower is
a divided figure, and
he doesn't speak for
Faulkner all the time.
That Faulkner is actually using
his neighbors sometimes
to pass judgment on him, just
as he is a dispenser of
judgment on others.
So this is neighbors in a
different light, but there's
yet another twist. So Faulkner
doesn't stop.
This is a constant switching
back and forth.
The swing of the pendulum from
the right being on the
neighbors' side to the right
being on Hightower's side, and
injury being done
to Hightower.
So this is the neighbors
in yet another right.
"Within two days"--
this is a little bit later.
Hightower is trying to
deliver a black baby.
The baby dies.
And within two days, rumors
were going around town.
"Within two days there were
those who said that the child
was Hightower's and that he had
let it die deliberately.
But Byron believed that even the
ones who said this did not
believe it.
He believed that the town had
had the habit of saying things
about the disgraced minister
which they did not believe
themselves."
So this is yet another
interesting portrait of how
people behave as
a collectivity.
That as a collectivity, we tend
to say things that we do
not actually, ourselves,
individually believe in.
This is the nature, quite often,
of rumors, or just kind
of standardized statements about
the current situation
that you just repeat
a certain line.
This is the nature of a line,
that it's fed to others, and
that we would mouth without
thinking about it.
And all of us do it.
It's not just people living
in a small town.
All of us tend to say certain
things that we haven't
actually personally thought
about, including damaging
things that we can say about
someone, like having a child
and allowing the child to die.
So this is the nature of rumor,
and Byron's insight--
and he knows these people
very well--
is that in one sense, it is
speech that seems hurtful that
actually doesn't have personal
malice in it.
So we have to be very careful
to distinguish that hurtful
speech can certainly inflict
injury on the person that that
speech is about.
It can inflict injury.
But something can't inflict
injury without having a lot of
personal malice in it, and
that is the crucial
distinction that Byron
wants us to make.
So we can see it constantly
things are
switching back and forth.
So we've been talking about
it since Tuesday--
the protagonist and supporting
cast constant switch,
background, foreground, dark
and light, Light in August,
Dark House, the other title for
the novel, kind and unkind
neighbors, dramatic narrative
versus undramatic narrative.
But all of this is coming to
head in the switch between
Lena Grove and Joe Christmas.
And this is a very interesting
narrative innovation on the
part of Faulkner.
We've seen in The Sound and
the Fury that it is a
four-section novel, right?
In As I Lay Dying, many, many,
too many to count, sections
completely split into tiny
little narratives.
And in this novel, it's really
the story of two people who
are strangers to each other.
It's really a huge challenge
how you could tell a story
about two people who have no
connection to each other, but
make the two stories
one novel.
So we'll see how that is
played out, and whether
Faulkner is completely
successful in turning these
two into a single story.
But today, we'll look at part
of what he's trying to do, I
think, and look at the
contrasting functions of Lena
Grove and Joe Christmas
in this novel.
Obviously we know that
one is a positive
catalyst for the community.
All the good things about the
community come out when we see
Lena Grove in action, and all
the bad things about the
community come out
when we see Joe
Christmas's part of the story.
So one is a positive catalyst,
the other is a negative
catalyst. But what is odd is
that even though this seems to
put them on opposite ends of the
narrative spectrum, quite
often Faulkner also contrives
to make them meet as well.
So it's a very interesting
kinship, actually, between the
two of them, even though
they seem so different.
So we'll talk about the
linguistic kinship, and also
the fact that both of them seem
to be passive receptacles
for what is coming to them.
So first, I think you
know this, but just
want to repeat it.
From Lena, this is the story.
"'Folks have been kind.
They have been right kind.'" It
is a very monotonous story.
In that sense, she's not very
great character, not a
completely helpful character to
Faulkner, because she only
knows one thing, and the
story never changes.
So he really has to introduce
a kind of a counterpoint to
Lena, whose very name already
precipitates a negative
response from the people who
are learning about his name
for the first time.
So he used to be the foreman.
Joe Christmas is just getting
a job from these people.
"'His name is what?' one said.
'Christmas.' 'Is he a
foreigner?' 'Did you hear of a
white man named Christmas?'
the foreman said. 'I never
heard of nobody a-tall named
it,' the other said."
So just to have the
name Christmas--
and I can't really think of a
name that is less neutral,
less innocuous than the
name Christmas.
But even for us, I think to hear
someone called Christmas,
there will be a kind
of strange response
from most of us.
And sure enough, there's a
strange response from these
two people.
So why is it that in
fact, we're not
entirely immune from that?
It's not as if the world that
Faulkner is creating is
completely apart
from our world.
I think in many ways, we're
part of that world.
But we're suddenly
seeing an extreme
reaction these two people.
All of a sudden--
nobody has even thought of him
as being a foreigner, suddenly
he's got to be a foreigner,
even worse than that.
Even foreigners don't have
a name like Christmas.
So maybe he's non-human.
Not quite that.
But he suddenly is in an
unclassifiable, but negatively
unclassifiable, category.
And the rest of the story
really plays on the
consequences, in many ways, of
having a name like Christmas.
But for now, I want actually
not to go there yet, but to
talk about a very strange kind
of kinship between Lena and
Joe, who otherwise seem
so different.
It's a completely
counterintuitive kinship and I
think it's also quite
deliberate.
So let's just go back to this
passage that we've talked
about last time, about Lena's
peaceful journey, "behind her
the four weeks, the evocation of
far, is a peaceful corridor
paved with unflagging and
tranquil faith and peopled
with kind and nameless faces and
voices," is the nature of
Lena's journey.
And oddly enough, the same kind
of language is used again
at a very different moment in
the story, for Joe Christmas,
when he's actually just about
ready to do the killing.
"'Maybe I have already
done it,' he thought.
'Maybe it is no longer now
waiting to be done.' It seemed
to him that he could see the
yellow day opening peacefully
before him like a corridor,
an arras, into a still
chiaroscuro without urgency.
It seemed to him that as he
sat there the yellow day
contemplated him drowsily, like
a prone and somnolent
yellow cat.
He would not move, apparently
arrested and held immobile by
a single word which had perhaps
not yet impacted, his
whole being suspended in quiet
and sunny space, so that
hanging motionless and without
physical weight he seemed to
watch the slow flowing
of beneath him."
It is exactly, one could just
put Lena right in there, and
it would have been a description
of the journey.
So I hope that it makes no sense
to you, why Faulkner
would want to use this for Joe
Christmas right before the
moment of violence.
I think this it's something
that cries out to be
interpreted by the reader,
why there should be the
duplication of the
once-appropriate language for
Lena into this completely
inappropriate and
counterintuitive content.
But all we can say is that this
is a quite heavy-handed
attempt on Faulkner's part to
generate a linguistic kinship
between the two of them.
Let's look at another instance,
and in fact, we see
it a little bit in the use of
gerunds in talking about this
moment of impending, incipient
violence, when he is held
suspended, but very peaceful.
And so this is the use of
gerunds, and we've seen that
in Lena, as well.
"'That far within my hearing,
before my seeing.' 'I will be
riding within the hearing of
Lucas Burch before his seeing.
He will hear the wagon,
but he won't know.
So there will be one within his
hearing before his seeing.
And then he will see me and
he will be excited.
And so there will be two within
his seeing before his
remembering." Completely highly
conspicuous use of the gerund.
And there's also a parallel,
highly conspicuous use of the
gerund for Joe Christmas.
"Knowing not grieving
remembers a thousand savage and
lonely streets." The same
use of the gerund, but in a
completely different context
and completely different
thematics.
So we really have to think a
little more about why it is,
even though the two of them
seem polar opposites that
Faulkner, nonetheless, sees
and is emphatic about the
kinship between the
two of them.
So maybe one way to think about
it is to once again
think about the relation between
an individual and a
collectivity, or at least
various representatives of
that collectivity.
And with Lena, we've seen that
she really is a passive
receptacle for all the Southern
hospitality that is
coming to her.
And maybe that's why she's
really not that interesting on
her own, that it really takes
action from other people to
vest her narrative with any
kind of action at all.
Left to her own devices
there will be no
story to tell, really.
And so she's a passive
receptacle in the sense that
she's really the narrative
device by which a community
gets to tell a story, by which
the action of a community gets
dramatized, and gets registered
within the compass
of a single individual.
And I would say that that is
also the narrative function of
Joe Christmas, as well.
That in many ways, even though
he's probably more
psychologically complex than
Lena, and it will be
interesting to think
about what kind of
psychology he has--
in spite of the complexity of
his psychology, he has a
similar narrative function in
the sense that he is the
vehicle by which somebody else's
action, somebody else's
drama, gets registered.
So he is the template on
which someone else
writes a dramatic narrative.
So this is the continuation of
that peaceful moment when he's
about to do the killing.
"He just sat there, not moving,
until after a while he
heard the clock two miles
away strike 12.
Then he rose and moved
toward the house.
He didn't go fast. He didn't
think even then, Something is
going to happen.
Something is going
to happen to me."
That syntactical
construction--
not, I'm going to do something,
but something is
going to happen to me, so
that I will actually
kill someone --
it's that bizarre transformation
of what would
have been a very familiar
sentence.
So even the most dramatic
fashion that he's responsible
for is cast as something that
is happening to him without
his volition almost.
And we see that this is
actually the logical
combination of a pattern that
has been the dominant pattern
all through his life.
So it goes back, this moment
goes back to when he was a
kid, when he was hiding and
eating toothpaste in the
closet of the dietitian, and
getting sick from the
toothpaste, and then witnessing
this completely
bewildering thing that is going
on between the dietitian
and the man who is
in her room.
And then all of a sudden he
throws up and the dietitian
realizes that there's someone
hiding in her closet.
So this is what happens when
she's furious to know that she
and the other man, that the
two of them are not
alone in the room.
"When the curtain fled back
he did not look up.
When hands dragged him violently
out of his vomit he
did not resist. He hung from the
hands, limp, looking with
slackjawed and glassy idiocy
into a face no longer smooth
pink-and-white, surrounded now
by wild and dishevelled hair
whose smooth bands once made
him think of candy. 'You
little rat!' the thin, furious
voice hissed; 'you little rat!
Spying on me!
You little nigger bastard!'"
So Joe has not really been--
intially, when all of this
is happening, people have
suspected there's something
maybe a little odd about his
racial composition, but nobody
actually up to this point, at
least nobody from the
administration--
has called him black.
And it's at this moment when
he is the unwitting,
involuntary, unintentional
witness to this scene that is
unfolding in the dietitian's
room that that adjective is
thrown at him.
And everything about the
description, is that he's
hanging from the hands of the
dietitian, he's witnessing a
face that has completely
transformed, the recipient of
that hiss, that is
coming at him.
Almost complete passivity
on his side.
So that he really is the
template on which the
dietitian is writing her own
furor and her own story.
One more example, and this is
his relation to his adopted
father, McEachern.
We have various ways to
pronounce that name.
I'm just going to pronounce
it "McEach-ern," you can
pronounce it any way you want.
"Then the boy stood, his
trousers collapsed about his
feet, his legs revealed beneath
his brief shirt.
He stood, slight and erect.
When the strap fell he did
not flinch, no quiver
passed over his face.
He was looking straight ahead,
with a rapt, calm expression
like a monk in a picture."
So once again, this is not the
kind of uncontrolled violence
that is coming from the
dietician, but the very
disciplined violence that is
coming from his own foster
father, adopted father.
But no matter what kind of
violence, it can be either out
of control, it can be totally
controlled, he is just there
like a saint, like a monk, just
totally calm, seemingly
untouched by that violence.
And that's part of the
interesting fact about Joe
Christmas, as well.
It's almost as if there's so
little content to him--
although I hesitate to say that,
because that doesn't
seem quite right, either.
But whatever it is that is
lacking in him, there's no
lashing out from him.
Even the killing is not really,
doesn't seem to be a
kind of a lashing out at
the way he's treated.
So he seems to be as blank a
slate as possible, although
he's probably not as blank
a slate as Lena is.
A lot more content than Lena,
but still a relatively blank
slate on which a various
succession of characters write
a very, very dramatic story.
So this is the structure, and
that's why there's this very
deep kinship between the two of
them, even though they are
totally different.